welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boston oh my god oh my god oh my god
spider-man no way home's long awaited
trailer is finally here it's actually
happening everybody shut up i'm gonna
watch this trailer with fresh eyes react
to it share my initial thoughts and then
in a separate video i'm gonna break it
down frame by frame for bringing guys
all the harder to spot details i gotta
make sure i can hear this good it's it's
august 23rd wandavision totally
predicted this oh guy i gotta get mt on
this empty empty it dropped it dropped
it dropped
are you ready to do this man yeah we had
to do it it's spiderman let's get it
let's get it
let's go
here we
go
oh look at this this is a good one some
suggest that parker's powers include the
male spider's ability to hypnotize
females
stop come on yes
can we just like stay up here all day it
is so crazy down there
that's right folks spider-man is in fact
peter it's been so long
i did not kill mysterio god the drones
did the drones that are yours
a good point
does anybody feel relieved about all
this what do you mean
i wouldn't now that everybody
don't do this to me not today don't take
jesus why then how do you tell someone
that you're spider-man
now everybody knows
but this is so heavy what's it to me i'm
hurting a lot of people
i've just been thinking about how to fix
all of this
halloween look like dr strange it looked
like it's strange like halloween what do
i owe the pleasure i'm sorry why is it
cold please we're safe everything's
frozen i think we're beyond you calling
me sir okay stephen
that feels weird but i don't know what
hey they're eating though
when mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up
i was wondering if maybe you could make
it so that he never did
strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous listen to wong
i won't
he's totally gonna do it
he's gonna do it he's gonna do it
that arrogant there's beer and the peter
parker is spider-man wait everyone why
is he helping
can't some people still know that's not
how the spell works
so mj is going to forget about
everything we've ever been through stop
tampering with the spell they're doing
ned he's
[Music]
oh my god
what just happened
what just happened we tampered with the
stability of space time i love the m.c.s
yourself that's a concept about which we
know frighteningly level lightning
the drain
is you trying to lift two different
lives
what's the what is that the longer you
do it spiders dangerous it becomes not
happy oh my god
oh my god
be careful what you wish for
who said it oh we got botanicals we got
them
we got them
hello welcome back how does he recognize
him right he's like look at that
oh my god
[Music]
the rainy verse has continued and we're
back kidding oh my god they're doing it
they're doing all of it i can't believe
this i literally my mind is blown
multiverse baby it's coming all right uh
empty based on this trailer we will be
pursuing in our contingency 17a uh so we
got a frame by frame breakdown we gotta
do i've already started doing my head i
know you probably have a bunch of theory
videos you gotta dive into this week so
i will wrap up here yes uh why why don't
uh you go get started i'll catch up i'll
get started on the breakdown these
videos
i'll do the breakdown we'll we'll be
good all right soon all right later
buddy now if your plans for today don't
include ascending the doom tower it's
time to download this video's sponsor
raid shadow legends use the links below
to download raid to your mobile phone or
pc what i like about the game is how you
can mix and match artifacts on a
champion to totally change the way they
fight and adapt them to different parts
of the game the big news in raid is that
they've just released a brand new
legendary champion designed after the
huge gaming personality ninja raid's
shadow legends made me a champion he's
got a katana a bow and arrow in a unique
origin story born a noble bannerlord
raiders laid waste to his family's manor
but he was spared and raised by the
shadowkin who taught him the arts of
shadow and war in secret ninja is one of
the most powerful and exciting champions
in the game and he's available for free
right now for everyone but he's only
available until october 15th after which
you won't be able to get him and if
that's not enough raid just released a
ton of amazing new features like clan
quests and rewards and even a brand new
clan shop with powerful items there's
also new champions to collect from
fragments in the doom tower like gwyneth
looks fierce every part of her covered
up in armor except the top of her legs
one must show a hint there's really
never been a better time to get started
if you want to get a huge head start in
raid all you have to do is hit the link
in the description or scan my qr code
and you'll get an epic hero chonoru who
is amazing in the doom tower 200 000
silver one xp boost one energy refill
and one ancient shard so that you can
summon an awesome champion as soon as
you get in game all this treasure will
be waiting for you here and once you're
in you can find me in game under the
name newrock2020 and if you're fast you
can join my clan and it's that easy just
click the link in the description and
i'll see you in the game holy [ __ ] they
are actually doing this it's official
spider-man no way home a movie set in
mcu continuity in which tom holland has
been peter parker since 2015 is using
the multiverse to reintroduce villains
from alternate cinematic universes
including not only alfred molina
from sam raimi's spider-man 2 in 2004
and jamie foxx's electro from mark webbs
the amazing spider-man 2 in 2014
now confirmed in this trailer it sounds
like willem dafoe as norman osborne
green goblin from the three sam raimi
films of the 2000's
oh my god well first off seeing alfred
molina on screen like this the
mechanized arms that tivia confidence it
almost doesn't feel real now molina said
an interview a few months back that he
would be transported from the moment of
his death in the river at the end of
spider-man 2 suggesting whatever this
doctor strange spell is might pluck
these alternate reality villains from
the moment they were supposed to die in
those other universes or maybe from
universes that these villains were
successful in ridding the world of
spider-man so strange's no more
spider-man spell could have just pulled
them from universes with no spider-man's
now the headline here obviously that was
a freaking pumpkin bomb that was a
signature weapon of the green goblin the
same design from the sam raimi films and
yeah that definitely sounded like the
voice of willem dafoe laughing now defoe
was rumored but not until now was he
confirmed maybe norman osborne was
plucked right before his oh seconds
before the glider impaled him oh my god
the implications here this doesn't
automatically mean the rumored
appearances by toby mcguire and andrew
garfield are confirmed as well now if
they are in the movie i highly doubt
sony would put them in a trailer i i
don't think we would know that for sure
until the movie comes out in december
and as a guy who's been following that
rumor mill fairly closely the evidence
that pointed to willem dafoe looked a
lot better than the speculation around
to maguire and andrew garfield which so
far just seemed based on people not
believing andrew garfield's denial in an
interview i recommend that you chill i
made plenty of videos breaking down all
the evidence and weighing how legit all
the evidence is and yes while i would
love this movie's final act to feature
brief cameos by alternate spider-man
like in a portal's open end game moment
i'm also totally okay with this just
being tom holland peter's story and to
see willem dafoe come back as norman
osborne is mind-blowing enough for me
like if all we saw of willem dafoe was
him just sauntering and cackling in a
mirror that would have been enough but
let's back up here what are they saying
cause this crossover exactly peter
parker goes to doctor strange asking him
to conjure a spell in which no one will
know he's spider-man but peter gets cold
feet maybe because it's so freaking cold
in the sanctum for whatever reason and
he steps into the spell and by doing
some tampers with it and causing it to
misfire and break reality so yeah by the
looks of it this movie is suggesting
that this is a separate multiversal
event from the one at the end of loki
potentially separate from anything that
happened in one division and what if i
guess you could argue that if he remains
planned for the sacred timeline to
unravel at the end of episode six he
could have synchronized that unraveling
with peter parker's destined tampering
with dr strange's spell in this movie
and it might not have been peter doing
anything wrong but something that was
always gonna happen anyway and peter
again has to take the blame for
something that wasn't really his fault
so since loki established that the
sacred timeline is an infinite loop and
that time is all occurring at once the
multiverse explosion at the end of that
series could have corresponding moments
that occur in each marvel title at
various points in time like juana
maximov suddenly hearing her sons from
another dimension and now peter's
interference with dr strange's spell
now by the looks of this you could
probably see this as a loose adaptation
of the spider-man one more day storyline
from 2007. if you aren't familiar with
this this would be after civil war and
during civil war peter parker went
public with his identity to initially
show allegiance with team iron man but
after civil war aunt may is slowly dying
from a gunshot wound and then uh peter
goes to doctor strange for help peter
ends up trying to do a spell without
strength's permission and it doesn't
work he actually gets injured so peter
walks away from that and ends up making
a deal with um well someone that he
didn't realize at the time and i'm gonna
tell you now please don't hate me this
is just what happened in the comics he
makes a deal with the fisto folks and
this deal with the devil is that mepisto
promises to erase the knowledge of
peter's secret identity from the world
and to make his life happy again let
peters to sacrifice his marriage with
mary jane and spoiler warning but it
ends with peter and mj having never
married and no one knows that spider-man
is peter parker harry osborne is alive
again and i am obligated to point out
that in this trailer i did see a sign
that likened peter parker with the devil
i said loose adaptation because um
people hated this storyline when it came
out it kind of retconned everything
about spider-man that fans had come to
love during the civil war era and in the
years that followed really a lot of
marvel titles would kind of try to
justify or explain away what had
happened until 2010 joe quesada just
kind of wrecked on things again with the
one moment in time story so if no way
home is doing one more day one
i don't think they'll make mephisto
behind it i just i just don't i think
mephisto is coming in the mcu at some
point maybe he's already there it's just
this movie already has a lot going on in
it and two i really only think the first
half of the movie is gonna change stuff
to that level but not to the extent one
more day did and whatever is done in the
first half of this movie i think the
second half of the movie is gonna
restore the more critical plot points to
not break the entire mcu kind of like
what one moment in time did either way i
am a bit surprised to see doctor strange
going along with this risky spell right
he's just appeasing a whiny kid who
really could just wait a year or two for
this all to blow over because you know
skrulls are going to start popping up
all over the mcu mutants are going to
start popping up all over the mcu hell
if some national news could just pick up
the local west view affiliate i think
those would be pretty big headlines the
one way to explain strange's choice is
maybe this doing disguise no i'm just
kidding maybe he's a super skrull maybe
mysterio's ongoing illusion hey we'll
have time to go to crazy bonkers theory
corner in the future i do think though
that strange is in a more smug place
after end game like after correctly
steering tony stark to the goal line he
might feel like he can tinker with the
universe with the scalpel like when he
was a surgeon or maybe part of the terms
of his spell are that uh peter has to
give up being spider-man be as strange
as tired of being in a world with too
many superheroes causing chaos that he
has to go clean up in either case this
might set up peter and strange to be
enemies in the movie you know there was
that shot of peter and doctor strange on
the train we could see another train top
battle something that catches doc oxide
now it is weird to see the sanctum
sanctuarium covered in ice kind of feels
like harry potter walking into
dumbledore's office to find a spell gone
awry never mind the ice peter wong tried
to cast an anti-global warming ax and
now it's the day after tomorrow in here
maybe when hulk crashed a hole into it
with heimdall's bifrost it could have
broken a magical barrier that's just
been difficult for strange and wong to
repair now that did happen in 2018 which
mean for wong to be unable to repair it
he would have had to have dusted
actually the official in-game screenplay
pretty sure said that he did whatever
i'm just loving how dark this movie
looks like and it's really leaning into
the magical elements of the multiverse
just really does look like a spider-man
doctor strange team up from the comics
and really how it is actually using the
multiverse to justify alfremolina.com
jimmy fox electro willem dafoe norman
osborne now in the mcu because if marvel
studios and sony pull this off folks
this could be the same logical framework
for how the mcu establishes other
alternate universe superheroes
deadpool's on his way already but like
x-men actors too charlie cox daredevil
they can restore evan peters as pietro
we can fix it all okay okay enough
goofing around i gotta dive deeper into
this i'm gonna analyze the vfx i'm gonna
find all the clues on the screens the
printed stuff the music everything in
the background i'm so excited to break
this down that video will come out next
on the channel just hang tight hold onto
your butts you can support new rockstars
by checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching it begins
[Music]
you